Have you ever had a nightmare that you’re
running down a long, dark hallway, getting
chased by something you can’t see?
The thing behind you isn’t fast, but that
doesn’t matter.
You can’t run forever, and the thing knows
it.
It is a patient predator.
It toys with its food.
At first, you move with speed and rhythm.
The metallic scraping noise behind you grows
quieter.
You run and stumble through the dark.
Your muscles start to ache and your lungs
burn.
Your pace slows.
It’s still coming.
You can hear the scraping getting louder.
You start to panic.
It’s completely dark.
You don’t know where you’re running or
even what you’re running from.
All you know - as you bump against the walls
and the sharp corners that rush towards you
- is that you can’t run forever.
You trip, fall, and pain explodes through
your leg as your knee shatters on the concrete
ground.
That scraping is getting louder.
You can barely breathe.
You can’t run anymore with your injury.
There’s no way to stop what’s coming.
There is no escape.
The scraping is right behind you.
You scream.
And then… you wake up.
Your heart is pounding like thunder in your
chest and your sheets are soaked with sweat,
but you’re safe.
You’re out of those awful, dark hallways.
But what if this wasn’t just a nightmare?
What if this scenario was real, and there
was no escape from the horror chasing you
in the darkness?
That’s what it’s like to have a close
encounter with SCP-1918, a sadistic, sentient
object that loves playing twisted games with
its prey.
But this monster never plays fair, and even
worse, it’s always just a simple door away.
It might even be hiding behind a door near
you, right now, waiting to start a game with
its new playmate.
But soon you’ll understand why some doors
should never, ever be opened, and why some
games are better left unplayed.
x
SCP - 1918 is an anomaly with two parts: SCP-1918
itself, and SCP-1918-2, the monster’s underground
lair.
The duo are a match made in hell, as the chambers
and hallways of 1918-2 are perfectly tailored
to 1918’s violent hobbies.
Nobody knows how long this anomaly has been
operating, but it’s probably behind countless
disappearances.
After all, 1918 has a habit of breaking its
toys...
The nightmare began in a small town in Maine,
with a population of only 226 people.
But that population was about to get lower.
People in the town began to report strange
noises at night, a droning, metal-on-concrete
scraping noise, like someone dragging a lead
pipe along the ground.
At first, people just ignored the sound.
It was all in their heads, or maybe just a
faulty oven or a washing machine on the fritz.
Anything that would allow them to forget about
the noise and get on with their daily lives.
But the noises were coming from below.
They could be heard out on the streets, most
audibly near manholes and sewer grates.
People started feeling unsafe in their homes.
The noises were spooking animals and children.
People were losing sleep.
That scraping they all tried to ignore was
beginning to get to them all.
Letters, emails, and angry phone calls to
the town council were piling up.
Something had to be done before the whole
town went crazy with fear.
The mayor authorized four utility workers
to investigate the source of the noise at
a local sewage treatment facility.
Considering the scraping was loudest near
the sewer grates, everyone just assumed that
whatever was causing all this must be connected
to the sewers.
Four utility workers were sent to investigate
the facility, only to find that the machinery
on site was working just fine.
The source of the problems must have been
coming directly from the underground sewer-lines
themselves.
The four workers, equipped with headlamps,
descended into a long service tunnel that
fed into the sewer system.
As they passed deeper into the tunnel, the
darkness around them became thicker.
It was a tangible presence that drowned out
the light of their headlamps, similar to the
anomalous phenomenon exhibited by SCP - 087.
When the utility workers tried to turn back,
they discovered another impossibility: It
seemed that the tunnel behind them had become
a solid concrete wall.
They were trapped, but where?
It was too dark to tell.
Confused and terrified, the four men stuck
together, attempting to find a way out.
It was too dark to see their hand in front
of their face, so all they could do was navigate
slowly by feeling the walls around them.
These walls felt oddly...crusty.
There was a kind of faint, metallic stench
hanging in the air, too, like old blood.
Something horrible had happened here, and
something horrible was about to happen again.
All they could do was keep moving and try
to stay calm.
Eventually, after hours of pawing at walls
in the dark, they found an open doorway.
One by one, they filed inside, only to feel
blinded when bright, white ceiling lights
suddenly switched on.
The room was all white, and filled with pipes,
large and small, running from wall to wall.
Just then one of the utility workers let out
an ear-splitting scream and pointed towards
the doorway.
His colleagues turned, and gasped in shock.
There was something outside the door, and
it was staring at them.
The object filled up almost the entire doorway.
It seemed like a demonic hobby horse, made
from a black-and-white, candy-striped metal
pole with a crude plastic head on top.
The head looked like a clown’s, with a wide,
toothy grin, but no visible eyes.
It was SCP-1918.
The utility workers were frozen as the object
leaned forward slightly, and slithered into
the room, the bottom of the metal pipe scraping
against the ground.
It was the exact same scraping noise that’d
been haunting the concerned townsfolk up above.
This was the thing behind it all.
And as the object moved, its metal pole started
to scrape words into the ground: Tik Tak Tow
None of the four utility workers were ever
seen again.
It didn’t take long for the SCP Foundation
to descend upon this quiet Maine town and
pick up the pieces.
All relevant officials were provided amnestics,
and cover stories were created for the disappearances
of the four utility workers.
The Foundation also commandeered the sewage
treatment facility that held the entrance
to SCP-1918-2, replacing all key roles at
the facility with undercover Foundation personnel.
SCP-1918 was given a Euclid' classification
due to the fixed nature of its hunting grounds,
and then the real research began.
The Foundation soon made some disturbing discoveries.
Entrances into the SCP-1918-2 area didn’t
follow any kind of logic.
The hunting ground of SCP-1918 can be entered
from almost any location, if you’re unlucky
enough.
There are currently 9 known entrances, including
5 sewage grates, 3 utility shafts located
in a sewage facility, and 1 toilet.
And these are just the ones the Foundation
knows about.
There are a huge number of ways to enter SCP-1918-2,
but to this day, nothing has ever been able
to leave.
SCP-1918-2 is contained twenty meters below
the streets of this unassuming Maine town.
Personnel, aside from Foundation-approved
D-class guinea pigs. are refused entrance.
Researchers have mapped out the layout of
1918-2 through seismic imaging of SCP-1918’s
movements.
There are 18 identical room pairs in SCP-1918-2,
or 9 compound rooms.
Rooms are differentiated between a '1' room
and a '2' room by crude carvings on the floors
outside of the individual rooms.
SCP-1918-2 is symmetrical, with half a meter
wide paths circling each compound room.
The only deviations to this construction are
the location of entrances on the sides of
each individual room, which vary randomly
while the location is “active.”
What exactly does SCP-1918 do in this private
little maze?
It plays games, of course.
Its two favorites - as indicated by the words
it scrapes onto the ground - are “Tik Tak
Tow” and “Memoree”
In Tik Tak Tow, 1918 moves to each “1”
room, leaving behind "X" markings on the floors
if the room is not already marked with an
"O" in a manner similar to a game of "Tic
Tac Toe''.
How a victim is meant to accomplish making
a mark or understand this process is unknown,
as no aides are given.
Blood is commonly used by victims to make
their markings, hence the rusty smell in many
of the rooms.
In Memoree, the trapped victim is rendered
unconscious by blunt force, presumably from
SCP-1918.
The subject regains consciousness in a random
section of the facility.
Success is marked by finding a “1” room
identical to the central room.
This event seems to possess a time limit,
as the subject is pursued by SCP-1918 throughout
the halls of the facility.
The subject "wins'' by marking the correct
room with an "O".
What happens if you win or lose these games?
It’s important to note that SCP-1918 is
very competitive, and doesn’t play fair.
If you win, the object will merely accuse
you of cheating, and start a new game.
This will happen again and again, until eventually…
you lose.
And when you do?
Well, take the horrifying encounter D-Class
personnel member D-2934 had with SCP-1918.
Wearing video and audio equipment, D-2934
was led into SCP-1918-2 by Foundation researchers.
When he eventually found his way to the central
room, 1918 challenged him to a game of Tik
Tak Tow.
And, against all odds, D-2934 won the game.
But 1918 didn’t take kindly to that.
It accused D-2934 of cheating, carving its
accusations into the ground before challenging
him to a deadly game of Memoree.
After hours of chasing, D-2934 eventually
lost his mind and was backed into a corner
by 1918.
As the object made its way towards him, he
panicked, ripped a pipe from the wall, and
began smashing 1918’s head.
As the plastic cracked under the force of
the blows, Foundation scientists could see
real brains inside.
D-2934 screamed, and the video feed cut off.
When the video turned back on some time later,
1918 stared into the camera with a different
head mounted atop its metal pole.
One that, just a few hours earlier, had belonged
to the unfortunate D-2934.
If there’s one lesson to be learned from
this terrifying anomaly, it’s that there
truly is no escape from SCP-1918.
Now go watch “SCP - 5031 - Yet Another Murder
Monster” and “SCP - 3999 - I Am At The
Center of Everything That Happens To Me”
for more unspeakable horrors from the Foundation
Archives!